euh notre émission spéciale consacrée à
la situation au proche- Orient continue
on va on va parler des risques de
contagion éventuellement on va parler
des conséquences diplomatiques
politiques de ces attaques terroristes
du du Hamas et de laariposte israélienne
pour commencer je vous propose un tour
d'horizon des réactions en France avec
Samia de chia depuis samedi matin les
réactions politiques s'enchaînent à
droite comme à gauche pour condamner
sans réserve l'attaque du Hamas contre
Israël le Hamas est une organisation
islamiste nous n'avons pas du tout
affire à la résistance palestinienne
incarnée par un Arafat même condamnation
au rassemblement national Marine Le Pen
s'est déclaré au côté de la démocratie
israélienne à gauche l'ex-président de
la République François Hollande affiche
aussi son soutien à Israël il y a là une
opération terroriste c'est vrai mené par
un groupe islamiste le Hamas qu'on
connaît mais il y a la volonté de faire
la guerre si le Parti socialiste le
Parti communiste et Europe Écologie Les
vert condamne sans réserve les exactions
du Hamas ce n'est pas le cas de la
France insoumise le communiqué de Alfi
publié samedi a déclenché une polémique
l'offensive armée de forces
palestiniennes mené par le Hamas
intervient dans un contexte
d'intensification de la politique
d'occupation israélienne à Gaza en
Cisjordanie et à Jérusalem Est nous
déplorons les morts Israéliens et
Palestiniens une manière de renvoyer sur
le même plan Israël et le Hamas pour le
gouvernement c'est inacceptable à
l'extrême gauche la violence verbale est
assumée la recherche du chaos revendiqué
et les ambigués révoltantes face au
drame de ces dernières heures craignant
à risque d'importation du conflit dans
l'Hexagone le ministre de l'Intérieur
Géral de Darmanin a annoncé des mesures
de protection des lieux communautaires
Juifs lundi soir une dizaine de
rassemblements se tiennent en France en
solidarité avec Israël et la Tour Effel
va s'illuminer aux couleurs de l'État
hébreu voilà je vous présente tout de
suite les invités de notre second débat
on continue d'analyser les conséquences
des attaques terroristes et du Hamas en
israë les conséquences notamment
politiques vous venez d' d'entendre des
réactions les conséquences diplomatiques
à à court et moyen terme avec Cédric
Perin bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
sénateur LR du Territoire de Belfort et
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères du Sénat Anne-Sophie s bcche
bonsoir et bienvenue directrice de
l'American Jewish commite à Paris et
docteur en géopolitique B Nabli bonsoir
et bienvenue à vous aussi professeur de
droit à lupec Paris 12 consultant
international au cabinet lisias Partners
et vous publiez relation international
droit théorie et pratique aux éditions
pédon avec nous également en duplexe
Antoine jardin qui est ingénieur euh de
recherche CNRS et Mathieu croissand
évidemment est resté à à mes côtés euh
je commence par onbondit sur les
réactions politiques en France et et et
notamment voilà le le le al j'allais
dire la tempête provoquée par les prises
de position de la France insoumise ou du
nouveau parti anticcapitaliste de de
Philippe Poutou euh à propos de la
France insoumise Jean Mélenchon parle de
lapidation médiatique permanente de LFI
pour qualifier ce qui s'est passé depuis
de jours Cédric Perin comment vous voilà
que que pensez-vous de ces prise de
position de Jean-Luc Mélenchon écoutez
il cherche je pense qu'il cherche un peu
les coups quand même Jean-Luc Mélenchon
il y a pas quand on est un responsable
politique on doit avoir une position
claire et je pense que dans ce cadre là
fi aujourd'hui est sortie de l'arc
républicain clairement on peut pas
aujourd'hui avoir un traitement
différencié pour ce qui s'est passé au
Bataclan avec ces malheureuses victimes
du du du 13 novembre 2015 et aujourd'hui
c'est c'est c'est ces victimes civiles
en Israël et notamment et notamment ces
260 jeunes qui participai à une rêveptie
et qui ont été abattu froidement par des
terroristes donc je pense qu'àé il y a
pas dans une situation comme celle-là
aujourd'hui on est plus sur un acte de
résistance on est sur un axe de guerre
et clairement je pense que etfi sortent
de l'arc républicain mais ils en sont
coutumiers et l'arc l'axe
islamogauchiste qu'ils ont pour habitude
de de de de de défendre même si ils s'en
défend effectivement est clairement
affirmé aujourd'hui ouais Anne Sophie
c'est bon bcche est-ce que c'est un
antisionisme qui sert à déguiser un
antisémitisme ça allit parfois en
l'occurrence c'est vraiment pour revenir
sur ce qui a déjà été dit ne pas
aujourd'hui être capable de condamner de
manière totalement implacable et sans
ambiguité l'attaque de cette
organisation terroriste contre des civil
israélien c'est c'est presque de la
complicité ensuite pour revenir enfin
c'est de la complicité c'est c'est avec
le terrorisme c'est c'est c'est rien
d'autre que ça et c'est totalement
inacceptable et bien sûr après pour en
revenir sur la question de l'antisonisme
oui à la fille joue régulièrement les
députés à l'Assemblée nationale jouent
régulièrement avec avec avec ce sujet et
et
masque et masque le fait en tout cas ne
veulent pas voir le fait que s sous
cette haine d'Israël on s'en prend au
français juif on le voit bien
aujourd'hui avec le renforcement de la
sécurité j'espère juste mais je j'ai des
doutes que ce n'est c'est pas un calcul
politicien h parce que je pense que dans
le dans leur esprit ça en est un alors
on va on va évoquer un éventuel
clientélisme B nabl votre avis làdus on
on peut soutenir le peuple palestinien
on sait ce qu'il subit depuis des des
années voir des décennies dans la bande
de Gaza sans avoir cette espèce de
double langage de la France insoumise
h oui c'est simple dès l'UR qu'il s'agit
de qualifier les faits auquels on a
insisté à savoir une attaque contre des
civils qui relève d'une qualification
qui est celle du terrorisme qui est
criticable de tous les points de vue
politique juridique et cetera c'est pas
le problème je crois la condamnation
doit être univoque naturellement par
contre j'éviterai à titre personnel à la
fois certaines analogies parce que dès
qu'on fait preuve d'une certaine rigueur
intellectuelle faire les comparaisons
avec le Bataclan ou même le 11 septembre
intellectuellement tout de suite c'est
limité c'est des analogies limitées on
n' pas le temps ici de revenir en détail
et quant à la l'alliance ou le fait de
qualifier un parti politique de complice
euh d'une organisation terroriste bah ça
relève du droit pénal donc c'est grave
aussi je referme la parenthèse mais
c'est le juriste qui parle là en
l'occurrence euh s'agissant de comment
alors les Palestiniens peuvent défendre
leur cause bah très simplement également
en se fondant sur le droit international
euh et là c'est on en revient peut-être
à l'opposition entre la stratégie de
l'Autorité palestinienne et celle du
Hamas le Hamas n'a jamais vraiment cru
dans la voie diplomatique et juridique
au sens international du terme alors que
l'Autorité palestinienne elle est née
précisément d'un processus diplomatique
qui nous renvoie aux accords d'Oslo donc
il y a là effectivement une vraie
opposition he violence politique voie
diplomatique et là le Hamas est allé
jusqu'au bout de sa sa logique et je
noterai une petite anecdote que pas
beaucoup n'ont noté enfin une anecdote
une petite remarque c'est peut-être une
une stratégie de leur part mais le Hamas
avait annoncé qu'ils allaient saisir la
Cour pénale internationale lundi c'estàd
aujourd'hui ce qui ce qui était assez
surprenant vu que encore une fois ce
n'est pas leur pratique naturelle ils ne
croi pas dans cette dans ce type de
stratégie c'était peut-être c'était
peut-être une forme de piège
communicationnel oui alors on a on a on
l'a évoqué dans la première partie il y
a eu un certain nombre certainement de
de pièges
communicationnels qui explique sans
doute l'absence de réaction des servic
sec peut-être que ça en fait partie vous
parliez de clientélisme je je je me
tourne vers Antoine jardin est-ce que
vous employez ce terme là pour
caractériser finalement la réaction de
de la France insoumise notamment celle
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon alors je crois que
vous avez soulevé un point important
c'est qu'il y a des gens au sein au sein
de la France insoumisse qui sont pas
d'accord du tout en fait sur la
caractérisation des faits et on a vu au
cours des deux derniers jours qu'il y
avait multiples positions et
interprétations au sein de ce mouvement
et il peut y avoir des dissensions qui
sont des dissensions sans aller jusqu'à
clientéliste parce que ça peut être
aussi des positionnements sincères ou
des incompréhensions de la situation euh
des gens qui ont en fait eu un réflexe
qui était celui des positions
habituelles dans les oppositions euh
entre groupes palestiniens et Israël et
ils se sont rendus compte au cours du
weekend que en fait on éétait pas dans
la situation d'un affrontement
traditionnel entre ces deux opposants on
était dans des faits beaucoup plus euh
violents d'atteintte directe à des
civils non combattants qui ont été tués
de sans froid et il a apparu dans
dernière position la France insoumiss
que c'était pas possible en fait de
tenir la position qui avait été défendue
initialement donc il y a eu une marche
arrière et cette marche arrière elle est
vécue douloureusement par certains
dirigeants du mouvement dont Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui se plaint d'être acculé à
faire marche arrière face à la situation
qui est intenable pour le mouvement
alors on va on va on va l'évoquer
évidemment Mathieu je vais vous donner
la parole tout de suite mais je voudrais
qu'on écoute ensemble une réaction celle
de l'écrivaine Rachel CAN qui est
l'invité de Rebeca fitousi dans sa
prochaine émission Un Monde un regard
elle réagit au au propos de Jean-Luc
méenchan et puis elle rappelle aussi
l'invitation du rappeur mdine aux
journées d'été d'Europe Écologie lev on
l'écoute les réactions qu'on a eu ce
weekend sont intolérables c'est de la
haute trahison à la France à la
République française mais on avait bien
senti tous ces tous ces signaux faibles
de l'extrême gauche l'extrême gauche
aujourd'hui est devenue infréquentable
mdine qui fait un jeu de mot qui ricane
de la choix et cette une de l'humanité
où il parle où il dit euh je combats
l'antisémitisme je ne l'ai pas entendu
cet influenceur de haine après ce
weekend et dans ce contexte je ne l'ai
pas entendu il y a ces silence notamment
des fervant défenseurs de l'antisém de
la lutte contre le racisme de la lutte
contre l'antisémitisme du féminisme il y
a ces silence qu'on n'oubliera pas
Matthieu on analyse ensemble justement
le le le fil des réactions chez chez LFI
oui parceil faut se méfier des des
grands mots aussi il faut plutôt
regarder les mots qui ont été employés
et plutôt aussi ceux qui n'ont pas été
employés et si vous voulez voir ce que
c'est qu'un rétro pédalage ben il
fallait écouter ce matin manuel bonpard
le coordinateur de la France insoumise
parce que depuis aujourd'hui il ne cesse
de leclamer sur tous ses réseaux sociaux
il condamne l'attaque du Hamas contre
Israël il y a deux jours encore ce mot
ne faisait pas partie de son vocabulaire
puisqu'on l'a rappelé contrairement la
quasittalité de la classe politique
Cuche comprise PS Parti communiste
écologie les députésfi avaient omis Siam
de condamner l'horreur de dans un
communiqué l'horreur à laquelle on a
assisté évidemment samedi un communiqué
qui a déclenché une énorme polémique al
on réexplique pourquoi parce que les
insoumis ils soulignaient
l'intensification de la politique
d'occupation israélienne dans les
territoires semblant donner un début de
contextualisation de compréhension de
justification aux attaques du weekend
ils y déplorent les victimes des deux
bords semblant envoyer le Hamas et
Israël dosado et puis ils invitaent dans
un V dans un vœux pieux les deux parties
à revenir autour de de la table des
négociations pour instaurer une paix
durable dans la région comme si le Hamas
voulait négocier quoi que ce soit il
l'avait prouvé à travers son histoire
alors aujourd'hui manuel monpard a fait
un pas il condamne certes mais qu'est-ce
qu'il condamne au fait hein encore une
fois les crimes de guerre de part et
d'autres dit-il mais pas un mot en
revanche et on l'a souligné tout à
l'heure pour qualifier les attaques
perpétrées par le Hamas or des hommes en
armes qui rafalent à la kalashnikov des
jeunes venus danser dans une fête et il
est peut-être là le parallèle avec le
Bataclan parce qu'on peut dire que ça
n'a rien à voir c'est juste
émotionnellement en tout cas ça fait
penser à cette image des des des hommes
en armes qui abattent des automobilistes
au passage ou qui enlèvent des
grands-mères ben ça porte un nom c'est
un attentat terroriste mais ce mot-là
est encore trop difficile à dire pour la
France insoumise où on préfère encore
l'ouvoyer en parlant d'offensive armée
c'était quand même le thème de départ ou
de crime de guerre comment
expliquez-vous cette gêne benah parce
qu'ils ne veulent pas que leur
condamnation du Hamas puisse passer pour
un assentiment d'Israël en général et du
gouvernement netaniaou en particulier
parce que ce serait contraire à leur
tradition la défense de la cause
palestinienne et c'est sûr qu'ils sont
pas aidés parce que ce gouvernement-l on
peut le rappeler d'extrême droite
extrêmement virulent extrêmement
vindicatif euh c'est c'est c'est c'est
c'est c'est ça pose un vrai problème
aussi qu'il faut qu'il faut dire et puis
la seconde explication c'est que c'est
contraire à leur calcul électoraux et je
suis désolé de mettre les pieds dans le
plat mais la France insoumise est en
effet persuadé que ces réserves
électorales elles sont où elles sont
dans les quartiers populaires et
qu'est-ce qu'ils se disent que dans les
quartiers populaires vivent de nombreux
Français issus de l'immigration et
qu'est-ce qu'ils ajoutent dans leur tête
dans leur raisonnement que parmi ces
nombreux Français issus de l'immigration
on compte beaucoup de nos concitoyens de
culture ou de religion musulmane vous
voyez un peu le raccourci et donc s'ils
sont musulmans ils sont probablement
anti-israëlien voir proamas un raccourci
au mieux ultra caricatural au pire
carrément insultant pour les gens
concernés mais d'où le malaise il est là
le malaise d'où les contortions d'où la
confusion entretenue de façon
subliminale entre les attentats et une
offensive militaire ou entre les
terroristes et entre les résistants
parce qu'à la France insoumise où le
monde se repeint en noir et blanc ben on
n'arrive pas à condamner le terror et à
fustiger la politique de la de
colonisation à marche forcée on n'arrive
pas à pleurer les victimes israéliennes
et à dénoncer les conditions de vie des
gaz oui il faut choisir à la France
insoumise il faut qu'il y ait des bons
il faut qu'il y ait des méchants mais la
réalité est hélas souvent beaucoup plus
complexe que des slogans est-ce qu'il y
a un risque de contagieux en France
voilà la question dont je voudrais qu'on
qu'on parle maintenant en étant le plus
mesuré possible il y a une marge de
soutien au peuple israélien qui se tient
en cette fin d'après-midi à Paris à
l'initiative du CRIF le Conseil
représentatif des institutions juives de
France plusieurs personnalités
politiques sont déjà arrivé Nicolas
Sarkozi ricioti ou encore le le sénateur
collégier verianck jado les
représentants des des institutions
juives dont le grand Rabin de France
avait été reçu un peu plus tôt cette
après-midi par le ministre de
l'Intérieur je vous propose d'écouter
Gérald
Arman on écoute le ministre de
l'Intérieur constater depuis samedi et
puis les événements absolument
inignobles et dramatiques qui se sont
déroulés en Israël des fits antisémites
puis une vingtaine de fit recensé sur le
territoire national un peu partout sur
le territoire national et la présence
massive des policiers des gendarmes ont
permis d'interpeller d'ailleurs 10
personnes dans des coins très différents
du territoire national pour ces gens qui
soi tagués des propos antisémites soit
menacés euh des lieux de culte ou des
personnes qui sortaient de de ces lieux
de culte ou de commerce que fréquent la
la communauté juive voilà au même
endroit Heim Corti le grand Rabin de
France craignit les risques
d'importation du conflit en France
Antoine jardin qu'en pensez-vous est-ce
que ce risque est réel est-ce qu'il est
surestimé est-ce que c'est trop tôt pour
en parler alors moi je suis très surpris
en fait du fait qu'on en parle aussi
ouvertement et on a effectivement le
souvenir en fait d'épisode ancien où on
craint que ce type de phénomène puisse
apparaître néanmoins et c'est ce que dit
le mise à l'intérieur on a plutôt des
comportements individuels et sporadiques
et aujourd'hui on n pas un phénomène
d'ampleur euh qui pose un problème
compliqué à gérer euh il faut avoir une
grande vigilance mais je pense qu'il
faut pas créer la polémique sur ce sujet
parce qu'en fait c'est générer les
conditions de la polarisation et c'est
créer une prophétie autoréalisatrice qui
va faire émerger ce type de clivage ce
type d'opposition je pense que la
situation est différente de ce qu'on a
pu avoir par le passé parce que la
nature du comportement du Hamas et la
nature des violences commises on les
voit directement dans les vidéos
reprises dans tout les médias les médias
occidentaux mais aussi les médias en
langue arabe et on voit bien que ces
violences sont des violences
indiscriminées contre des civils
désarmés et ça beaucoup de gens en
France quelle que soit leur confession
ne l'acceptent pas et donc il faut aussi
voir qu'il y a dans ces violences là
l'occasion de changer le regard d'un
certain nombre de personnes sur ce que
c'est que le Hamas parce que le Hamas en
fait n'a pas motivé son action par des
questions territoriales il l'a motivé
par la question de la gestion de
l'esplanade des MOS et il a saisi une
opportunité politique pour le concentrer
sur une question religieuse euh donc
c'est un sujet qui est très différent
des autres épisodes qui ont pu avoir
lieu et je crois qu'il faut au contraire
éviter de créer les conditions qui
seraient favorables à une polarisation
sur ce sujet Cédric per per votre avis
là-dessus et puis peut-être le
dispositif qui est mis en place dans
votre département j'imagine qu'il y a
une un renforcement des des mesures de
protection le même dispositif que dans
les autres départements c'est-à-dire
queune des mesures de protection
particulières sur les lieux de culte
musulmans euh israélite pardon et donc
moi je pense qu'il faut se garder d'être
trop alarmiste sur ces sujets je pense
que l'objectif du ramas très clairement
en en en diffusant les images qu'il
diffusent c'est de radicaliser les
positions ces gens-là ont horreur des
modérés en fait ce qu'ils veulent c'est
que deux franges de c'est l'Occident
contre contre l'Orient c'est-à-dire
c'est enfin de mon point de vue
aujourd'hui les images qui sont qui sont
diffusées ont pour objectif de
radicaliser les les différentes parties
alors on verra comment les choses vont
évoluer dans les dans les dans les jours
qui viennent mais c'est vrai que le les
coupures d'eau d'électricité les
attaques sur gazard vont évidemment euh
j'allais dire être opposé à la situation
des otages qui sont évidemment détenu
dans dans dans la bande de Gaza et qui
vont les unes et les autres ces images
j'allais dire euh exciter un certain
nombre de de comportement et c'est ça
qui m'inquiète plus qu'aujourd'hui que
la situation qui est celle de la France
don je voudrais qu'on essaie d'éviter de
trop parler c'est V c'est pas la peine
de faire des des des prophéties
autoréalisatrices je suis assez d'accord
avec Monsieur jardin de ce point de
vuelm pour l'instant je pense que la
situation tient et moi sa je rentre de
copenhag je suis rentré ce matin j'ai
regardé les vidéos il y a eu des
manifestations en Suède il y en a eu à
Sydney il y en a eu vous l'avez vu sans
doute à Times Square à New York il y en
a eu dans le monde entier des
manifestation pro pro proamas pro pro
palestinienne palestinen en France elles
sont interdites pour l'instant on il y a
eu beaucoup d'autres manifestations
interdites auquel des quelques élus avec
des écharpes ont participer également
donc il faut être prudent làdessus ouais
un dernier mot làdessus parce
qu'effectivement on va pas passer la
totalité du débat peut-être avec vous B
na le fait que justement une une
manifestation propalestinienne a été
interdite risque de trouble à l'ordre
public c'était quoi c'était une
provocation aussi vite vous trouvez pas
ça logique qu'elle soit interdite parler
de celle qui trèsv aujourd'hui FR ou
notamment à Lyon oui et puis
effectivement si je vous ai posé la
question savoir si c'était celle
d'aujourd'hui c'est que j'ai
l'impression qu' il y a une
jurisprudence qui tend à se dessiner du
côté du ministère de l'Intérieur
vis-à-vis des de toutes
manifestations en soutien au
Palestiniens alors le problème c'est que
si cette jurise prudence devait se
confirmer euh ça conforterait ceux qui
considèrent qu'il y a véritablement une
une politique et une perception à
géométrie variable vis-à-vis de ce
conflit euh alors non seulement du point
de vue international et là on comprend
on y reviendra peut-être parce que
derrière notre impression de faire bloc
parce que l'Occident fait bloc derrière
Israël nous sommes en
réalité relativement isolé et c'est très
intéressant de prendre la carte du monde
avec ceux qui qui ont condamné euh le
Hamas et ceux qui soit euh manifestent
une forme d'indifférence soit on
simplement fait pris acte et finalement
le conflit aussi russo-ukrainien C deux
cartes qui peuvent se cal je veux bien
qu'on y revienne un peu plus tard mais
je je je reprends le mot jeis vous donne
la parole tout de suite là-dessus le mot
provocation c'estàd que est-ce qu'on
peut organiser il y en a eu dans
d'autres pays effectivement mais est-ce
qu'on peut organiser aujourd'hui une
manifestation proalestinienne sans
donner le sentiment finalement de de de
de d'être favorable au amas et de dire
bravo vous voyez ce que je veux dire
c'est particulrement choquant quoi d' ou
oui bien sûr oui on dirait presque une
oui soit on peut l'interpréter comme
une comme comment dire une provocation
soit aussi comme une manifestation
préventive par rapport à ce qui se
dessine à Gaza dans la mesure où il a
été annoncé alors pas un blocus puisque
ce blocus existe déjà il est subi depuis
un siège un siège complet mais on
basculerait dans un siège qui signifie
concrètement coupure d'eau coupure
d'électricité et cetera mais dans tous
les dans toutes les hypothèses
effectivement il y a un problème de
timing dans l'interprétation qu'on
puisse bon on va parler diplomatie
vraiment dans dans un instant votre
votre avis là-dessus et on boucle ce ce
chapitre oui oui non juste une seconde
sur les risques sécuritaires parce que
on peut aussi prendre le sujet à
l'envers la réalité c'est qu'il y a eu
par le passé des risques sécuritaires et
très concrètement une augmentation des
actes antisémites en France comme ils
sont mesurés chaque année par le
ministère de l'Intérieur dans les
périodes de tension dans la région c'est
malheureux c'est même inacceptable et
intolérable quand on y pense de se dire
que lorsqu'un conflit surgit à des
milliers de kilomètres d'ici on doit se
soucier de la sécurité des Français
juifs c'est inimaginable effectivement
on aimerait ne pas le faire la réalité
c'est que ça a déjà lieu et que ce
renforcement il est nécessaire il y a
pas de prophétie autoréalisatrice mais
il y a aussi une peur des Français juif
il faut le dire nous on la mesure
d'ailleurs dans l'étude qu'on publie
tous les 2 ans radiographie d' en France
on voit que les Français juifs dans ces
périodes ont davantage peur adoptent des
stratégies d'évitement de certains
quartiers évitent de dire qu'ils sont
juifs dans les lieux publics c'est une
réalité très très concrète et le risque
sécuritaire il est mesuré de manière
très concrète il s'agit pas de de
fantasmer quoi que ce soit il s'agit pas
d'en parler trop évidemment mais c'est
c'est nécessaire et c'est utile
d'anticiper ce genre de risque plutôt
que que d'y répondre quand quand il
survient évidemment allez on parle
diplomatie tout de suite on va
s'intéresser aux conséquences de de ces
attaques on va commencer par la France
grâce à Steve Jourdain qui va pouvoir
nous rejoindre de nouveau sur ce plateau
rebonsoir Steve alors la réaction
française évidemment condamnation de
l'attaque terroriste sur Israël et puis
des promesses oui pour comprendre ce que
fait actuellement la France en coulisse
il faut se pencher sur les réseaux
sociaux Thomas oui regardez Paris a très
vite condamné l'attaque de samedi
Emmanuel Macron a publié publié un tweet
en trois langues dont un en hébreux
qu'on voit pour dire que la France
tenait au côté des Israéliens toujours
sur Twitter la diplomatie française fait
un point et bien sur les actions qui
sont actuellement menées dans la matinée
de samedi jour de l'attaque Emmanuel
Macron s'est entretenu avec abdelfattar
alissi président égyptien mais aussi
avec marboudabbas le président de
l'Autorité palestinienne et Najib Mikati
le Premier ministre libanais objectif de
ces consultations désamorcer les
violences c'est ce qu'écrit le ministère
des Affaires étrangères il faut éviter
un embrasement de la région la France
poursuivra ses efforts en ce sens dans
les jours et les semaines à venir le
problème et bien c'est que ni Mahmoud
Abbas don la France il a encore quelques
mois on se'en rappelle peut-être
quelques mois son successeur ni le
Premier ministre libanais non'ont la
main sur le diréroulé actuel des
événements au Proche Orient la France
dispose-t-elle d'autres leviers dans la
région dispose-t-elle encore de certains
leviers c'est la question hein car
historiquement on seen rappelle la
France a joué un rôle majeur au
ProcheOrient prenez par exemple l'Iran
qui a salué les attentats de samedi et
qui est soupçonné d'avoir et bien joué
un rôle de leur organisation et bien
entre Paris et téran les relations sont
actuellement détestables début septembre
Emmanuel Macron réunit les ambassadeurs
à l'Élysée et il dit la chose suivante
écoutez-le rien ne justifie la détention
de six ressortissants français
aujourd'hui dans les prisons et dans des
conditions inadmissibles en Iran
troisème élément que je ne veux pas
oublier c'est aussi d'encadrer les
activités de déstabilisation régionale
que l'Iran a mené ces dernières années
et pour tous nos partenaires c'est un
point indispensable Emmanuel Macron qui
fait référence à un rôle iranien au
Liban où la milice du détient
actuellement plus de
140000 missiles pointés vers Israël il
na fallu que quelques petits jours et
bien pour que théran répondre au chef de
l'État
écoutez je conseille à Monsieur Macron
de se concentrer sur la situation en
France au lieu de s'intéresser au
question d'ingérence dans d'autres pays
l'Iran a toujours joué le rôle le plus
constructif en aidant et en soutenant le
Liban manifestement la France pas
compter sur la relation parisérant pour
une désescalade sur qui d'autrre le
Qatar le Qatar peut-être l'un des plus
gros ban banquier du Hamas DOA donne
l'équivalent de 360 millions de dollars
par an à l'organisation islamiste
chiffre de 2021 il le fait avec
l'autorisation d'Israël il faut le
rappeler cet argent a sans doute servi à
armer les terroristes qui ont mené
l'attaque samedi en coulisse ce qu'on
entend Thomas c'est que des discussions
sont sans doute en cours pour un échange
d'otage israélien et de prisonniers
palestiniens détenus en Israël des
discussions sous l'Égypte précisément du
Qatar la France pourrait peut-être
peut-être agir sur ce lier pour avoir un
petit impact sur les événements et pour
l'instant elle est surtout spectatrice
du drame merci Steve Cédric Perin est-ce
que notre diplomati est démuni d'une
certaine façon face à ce qui se passe
là-bas écoutez il y a depuis quelques
mois maintenant on s'interroge à savoir
avec qui la France parle encore h et la
vraie question elle est
là Macron appelle marmud d'Abbas don
qu'il voulait remplacer il y a quelques
mois il appelle Mikati au Liban qui n'a
plus de
pouvoir la vérité c'est qu'on a pas de
contact avec le ramas à priori et que on
est dans une situation avec le
absolument détestable avec l'Iran donc
la vra question c'est avec qui on parle
encore et quels sont les moyens pour
nous d'agir étant entendu je pense que
jusqu'à présent dans l'histoire de notre
pays on a été quand même un des un des
rares pays au monde qui était capable de
parler avec tout le monde et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui la situation c'est
considérablement compliquée pour la
France on le voit sur un multiple sur de
multiples théâtres d'opération donc moi
ce que j'p les saouiens il jouent un
rôle
ah la vraie question c'est que enfin moi
je suis je reste intimement persuadé
mais c'est a été démontré pendant pas
mal de de dans pas mal de de sujets ce
weekend
que l'Iran instrumentalise le le le les
Palestiniens aujourd'hui l'Iran n'a que
faire de la Palestine c'est juste un
pion dans les chiquier mondial alors il
faut expliquer qu'il y avait un
processus on va dire de normalisation
entre Isral de normalisation il est
absolument capital parce que certains
pensent et je pense qu'ils sont pas loin
de la vérité que
l'Iran a poussé en tout cas leur Hamas
ou en tout cas à organiser cette attaque
pour faire en sorte justement de faire
tomber ce processus de normalisation
entre l'Arabie Saoudite et Israël donc
aujourd'hui l'Arabie Saoudite est dans
une situation compliquée où elle ne peut
pas faire autrement que de condamner
malheureusement les actes terroristes
mais où sans doute elle aimerait aussi
que le processus de normalisation puisse
puisse avancer et donc l'objectif
d'Israël est de de l'Iran est plutôt
atteint en en empêchant le Contin la
continuité de ce processus deisation moi
ce que je voudrais dire c'est que les
Iraniens ont inventé le jeu d'échec ENF
en tout cas ils se disent l'avoir
l'inventé l'avoir inventé les Russes
sont d'excellent joueurs d'échec
aujourd'hui les Russes et les Iraniens
qui sont alliés clairement jouent sur un
échiquet mondial et posent leur pion à
droite à gauche et nous on continue de
n'avoir aucune vision sur un d'un
échiqué mais de jouer avec des pions
par-ci par là sans avoir une vision
globale donc je pense qu'il faut il
faudra qu'à un moment donné on commence
à avoir une vision un peu plus globale
et un peu plus euh un peu plus long
terme ce qui n'est pas le cas leème des
démocra auourd'i c'est qu'on a une
vision à l'élection suivante alors il y
a quand même une c'est en ce soir ça a
été annoncé par nos confrères de
l'Agence France Presse il y aura Joe
Biden il y aura Emmanuel Macron il y
aura Olaf Scholz pour l'Allemagne rich
sunac pour le Royaume-Uni voilà une
espèce de mini conférence téléphonique
qui est organisé donc il y a quand même
une volonté effectivement de Paser
inerte face à cette offensive B que j'ai
pas dit qu'on voulait rester inerte j'ai
bien
compris j'ai bien compris et de vision
et de vision que que Ch alors on va
pousser effectivement la démonstration
et l'analyse sur l'Arabie Saoudite le
processus de normalisation mais il a il
y a aussi dans dans le si on essaie de
comprendre ce que cherche le ramas c'est
peut-être aussi de tout simplement
remettre la question palestinienne sur
la carte quoi c'estàdire que on avait
l'impression que c'était plus un sujet
exactement alors ce qui a été dit est
vrai enfin je partage l'analyse
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères et de la défense dans la
mesure où incontestablement l'Iran avait
intérêt à ce qui s'est passé a démontré
sa capacité à peser sur la relation
entre Israël et et le Hamas et sur sa
capacité à neutraliser le processus de
normalisation entre l'Arabie Saoudite et
Israël mais le Hamas et les Palestiniens
plus largement avaient aussi intérêt à
stopper ce ce processus de normalisation
comment en faisant la démonstration
qu'au-delà de cette dynamique
historique la question palestinenne se
posait de manière autonome et qu' qu'on
ne pouvait pas la neutraliser
Hend
présentre neutralis en la paix via le
soutien économique de l'Union européenne
via des fonds ou du Qatar et cetera et
que il y avait une question politique
une question nationale de l'existence
d'un peuple sans état et qui considère
qu'il s'agit là d'une injustice
historique donc il y a ce pointl qui est
fondamental et au-delà de la TR j'ai dit
euh qu'on vit depuis samedi et qui va
perdurer
euh une fois que cette séquence violente
sera terminée là pour le coup l'enjeu
diplomatique et politique restera et
c'est là où finalement peut-être que la
question se posait juste un point sur la
France la France était audible
lorsqu'elle avait cette position qu'on
qualifie traditionnellement de
golomiterandienne qui consistait à
rappeler les termes du droit
international à savoir que il y avait un
peuple qui voyait ses droits euh violé
par un occupant qui menait une qui qui
mène une politique coloniale et qui lui
permettait infin d'être audible parce
que c'était relativement dissonant au
sein du monde occidental aujourd'hui
Emmanuel Macron va se retrouver avec ses
ses pirres que vous avez rappelé mais on
n'entend plus la singularité française a
plus de singularité française votre avis
Ann Sophie B je vous redonne la parole
juste après oui mon avis c'est
qu'effectivement il semble assez quand
même clair que l'Iran a activé le Hamas
dans cette attaque parce que
effectivement ce rapprochement entre
l'Arabie Saoudite et Israël était en
train d'être négocié mais non seulement
en train d'être négocié mais imminent et
et l'Iran visiblement a eu tellement
peur que ça se passe qu'il a été prêt à
envoyer le Hamas à sa propre destruction
parce que c'est exactement ce qui va se
passer c'est une opération suicide du
Hamas on sait que la réponse d'Israël va
être et il l'ont annoncé de de détruire
cette organisation et et et et sur et
sur la cause ministre naniao l'a souvent
annoncé on pouvait reprendre ou là on
est sur une autre dimension je pense
qu'il y a vraiment un changement de
paradigme et juste juste pour ne pas
enfin on va aboutir à une séquence on va
retrouver le Hamas infin on se dira mais
tiens on n pas en tout cas ce que je
voulais ajouter simplement c'est que en
torpillant les espoirs de paix entre
Israël et l'Arabie Saoudite on torpille
aussi des espoirs de progression sur le
processus de pays israëlou palestinien
puisqu'il y avait dans les éléments de
négociation des éléments euh sur le
conflit et notamment l'Arabie Saoudite
avait une ligne très ferme là-dessus et
il y avait des espoirs de progrès et
d'ailleurs au moment de la signature
aussi avec les Émirats Arab Unis le
conflit a joué puisque je sais pas si
vous vous souvenez mais à l'époque euh
le gouvernement israélien de l'époque
avait annoncé l'annexation qui a
finalement été abandonné et qui
visiblement était un des éléments de
négociation et qui ont finalement permis
euh de de d'accéder à cette
normalisation et un mot simplement sur
l'analogie avec le 11 septembre puisque
vous parlez de la France qui va se
réunir aujourd'hui je je pense que ce
que vit Israël aujourd'hui auourd'hui
c'est son 11 septembre 2001 après on
peut parler des termes motif vous avez
raison géopolque mais sur le plan de la
sidération si vous voulez 700 morts
aujourd'hui en Israël c'est comme si on
avait aujourd'hui 6000 morts 6000 morts
français des femmes des enfants une
monstruosité mais inouie dans dans
l'attaque qui aussi pour revenir sur le
malais simplement je m'arrêterai là ce
que le ramas démontre aujourd'hui c'est
que ce que certains observateurs et
notamment alifi ont voulu nous faire
croire pendant des anné que finalement
le ramas était un groupe nationaliste
parmi d'autres qui finalement était en
quête du pouvoir un groupe nationaliste
frèr musulman et cetera aujourd'hui dans
une démarche nous a démontré que sa
démarche est
apocalyptique terroriste une volonté
d'anation de de de de la population
israélienne et la réponse elle sera
implacable oui mais elle prendra sans
doute du temps on en a parlé en première
partie notamment avec les otages Cédric
per oui oui je jeis entièrement d'accord
avec ce qui vient d'être dit mais je
pense que concrè aujourd'hui la réponse
qui va être celle d'Israël maintenant va
conditionner aussi la suite de des
opérations parce que l'objectif du ramas
en diffusant les images qu'il diffuse
sur les réseaux sociaux est aussi
j'allais dire d'exciter ou d'énerver en
tout cas l'opinion publique
international et et et notamment
netaniaahou et si la réponse est
violente l'objectif sera du Hamas sera
atteint c'est-à-dire qu'il vont coaliser
en tout cas autour
d'eux le monde musulman et les l'Arabie
Saoudite ne pourra pas faire autrement
que de condamner l'action d'Israël et
les
accords la normalisation sera anéantie
donc évidemment et le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui c'est un piège qui qui
est fait à netanahou un piège duquel je
ne vois pas comment il peut se sortir
ouis deux réactions internationales qui
vont ouvrir le tout dernier chapitre de
ce débat d'abord celle de Joe Biden le
président
américain en ce moment de tragédie je
tiens à leur dire ainsi qu'au monde
entier et aux terroristes du monde
entier les États-Unis sont au côté
d'Israël nous ne manquerons jamais de
les
soutenir et puis une autre réaction
celle du président turc REP Tayip
Erdogan une paix durable au Moyen-Orient
n'est possible que par une solution
durable au conflit Israël au palestinien
à ce stade comme nous l'avons toujours
exprimé il est de la plus haute
importance de préserver la perspective
de la solution à deux état sur la base
des frontières de
1967 la création d'un État palestinien
indépendant et géographiquement intégré
avec Jérusalem pour capitale est une
exigence qui ne peut plus être
reportée voil la création d'un État
palestinien c'est aussi la solution
rappelée soutenue par la Russie de
Vladimir Poutine c'est un peu binaire ce
que je vais dire mais Turquie Russie
d'un côté de l'autre côté Union
européenne et États-Unis c'est le le le
front les mêmes alliances à l'œuvre sur
la guerre en Ukraine depuis 19 mois que
l'on voit là se se répéter ce
c'est le nouvel ordre mondial qui se
dessine avec quelques nuances euh qui
sont liées à des affinités soit
stratégiques soit idéologique je noterai
notamment au sein de ce qu'on appelle le
sud global le soutien de l'Inde à Israël
mais pas n'importe quel Inde c'est
l'Inde dirigé par un gouvernement
d'extrême droite de la même couleur
politique que le gouvernement israélien
en exercice pour ça quand vous dites que
il y a malgré tout un processus de paix
qui perdure c'est pas du tout dans la
feuille de route du gouvernement actuel
en Israël qui est formé notamment de
suprémacistes dont un ministre qui a été
condamné pour terrorisme et d'autres
membres qui avaient appelé à la mort
d'Isaac Rabine donc on a en face quand
même un gouvernement israëlien qui est
vraiment d'une nature très singulière et
j'attends le moment où il va annoncer
être à la tête du monde libre là on
risque d'être dans un schéma un peu
particulier euh où on va se regarder je
pense
parce que précisément le monde est
complexe à une reconfiguration où les
schémas binaires mais vous l'avez dit
sous sous le ton de la boutade ne vont
pas ne sont pas à la hauteur de la
complexité des des enjeux oui et
d'ailleurs l'Arabie Saoudite négocier le
rapprochement avec Israël et quand je
parlais du confliit israpestinen c'est
dans le le cadre de la normalisation et
des négociations où c'était pas
totalement occulté on voit aussi la
comment la diplomatie marocaine par
exemple a toujours essayé de remettre
dans le jeu et dans les négociations le
conflit c'est c'est là c'est de de de ça
que que je voulais parler et sur la
complexité oui puisque l'Arabie Saoudite
c'est aussi récemment un peu rapproché
de l'Iran et on voit bien qu'il y a un
changement total de paradigme au
Moyen-Orient les alliances se font plus
uniquement sur la division sunnite
chiite et cetera mais chacun joue en
fonction de ses intérêts peut nouer des
alliances de court terme de moyen terme
ne n'exclut pas enfin l'un n'exclut pas
l'autre et d'ailleurs au moment du
rapprochement Iran Arabie Saoudite
certains disaient ah bah du coup c'est
fini avec Israël mais en fait pas du
tout ça se poursuivait aussi dans le
même temps avec Israël céric Perin
est-ce que je je repose la même question
que j'ai posé tout à l'heure à à ber sur
finalement l'obj l'un des objectifs du
du ramas même si on est d'accord il y a
certainement le l'Iran en sain quand
même de remettre la question
palestinenne et donc la question de la
création d'un État palestinien
finalement au cœur d' des enjeux
diplomatiques du moment alors que ça ne
l'était plus oui mais on est bien
au-delà de ça euh moi je je pense que
les responsables politiques français et
et européens devraient le faire je pense
qu'il faut aussi alerter l'opinion
publique sur les les les sur le les
souhaits de Vladimir Poutine pardon en
en réorganisant la géopolitique mondiale
son objectif c'est quoi c'est tout
simplement de de d'obtenir par
différents canaux comme il le fait en
Afrique au Mali au Niger ou ailleurs une
espèce de radicalisation alors en
Afrique ça se passe grâce à une
ouverture claire des frontières à
l'envoi de migrants en
Europe en Palestine ça se passe grâce à
une radicalisation liée à des actes
abominables qu'on diffuse sur les
réseaux une radicalisation de notre
propre pays c'est-à-dire que l'objectif
c'est quoi c'est de changer nos
gouvernements par par l'élection par par
par une radicalisation de de nos
populations et aujourd'hui on voit bien
dans les différents pays européens ce
qui se passe avec une arrivée de de de
des extrêmes et je pense qu'on n'est pas
AB à l'abri de cela parce que mais mais
je pense qu'il faut que chacun comprenne
que derrière tout ça c'est une
manipulation qui est en en place avec
une espèce de de de de lutte
informationnelle qui est en qui est en
jeu et il faut qu'on puisse y y répondre
et je pense que c'est du devoir des des
élus aujourd'hui que d'expliquer en tout
cas et des journalistes aussi que
d'expliquer quelle est la politique
réelle qu'il y a derrière tout ça
l'objectif c'est de changer nos
démocraties à l'image des gouvernants
que que que Vladimir Poutine aimerait
avoir dans nos pays les chos soit clair
un dernier mot B nabl on parlait dans la
première partie de l'émission finalement
du piège tendu par le ramas est-ce que
l'État d'Israël peut faire autre chose
que une réplique militaire puissante
peut-être attendue par une partie d'une
grande partie de sa population après ce
traumatisme dont nous parle HM alors
rapidement oui euh là Israël est dans le
cadre de ce qu'on appelle la légitime
défense euh Israël a été attaqué il a le
droit du point de vue international de
réagir euh là où il pourrait trouver un
compromis et peut-être entretenir
l'image positive de victime qu'il a
actuellement c'est de rester dans les
canons du droit international c'est même
en cas de légitime défense vous ne
pouvez pas vous affranchir du respect du
droit international notamment très
concrètement bombarder des bâtiments
civils si vous commencez à bombarder des
bâtiments civils une proportion de
victimes civiles à centaines là non
seulement vous vous prendrez le risque
de voir l'opinion publique en tout cas
l'opinion occidentale basculer
relativement mais surtout voir
l'argument du droit international
basculer et juste un élément très
intéressant par rapport à ce conflit oui
c'est vous avez parlé de diplomatie
aujourd'hui on peut plus penser la
diplomatie seulement à travers les
relations entre état vous avez été vous
avez les sociét civile qui pèse
également et c'est pour ça qu'il y a une
difficulté côté des États arabes à
pouvoir assumer la normalisation parce
que leur société civile ne suivent pas
forcément le choix de leurs dirigeants
notamment en matière de de normalisation
on peut la tester on l'a vérifier lors
de la Coupe du Monde au Qatar notamment
c'était assez significatif mais au-delà
du folklore il y a une réalité sociale
très forte je termine avec cette toute
dernière information qui vient de nous
parvenir malheureusement on est plutôt
dans une escalade le Hamas qui menace de
tuer des otages pour en action au raid
israélien merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat à cette émission spéciale
demain évidemment dans la matinale il
sera encore question des
conséquences de ces attaques terroristes
en Israël et des conséquences politique
en France puisque Orian monsini reçoit
Olivier fort le premier secrétaire du
Parti
[Musique]
socialiste
foreign